you had a premiere in Venice at a and
this is this is a how long is the
beginning of the summer right this is no
this is respray three weeks ago oh
really
yeah yeah but this okay a couple of
weeks ago you have this premiere in in
Venice and this is the big deal and this
movie you've been working on this for so
long and it's what's been this elegant
thing and the skies opened up and it was
I heard an incredible storm yeah while
you were trying to have her from yeah it
was one of those things like when you
watch a movie in New York you know like
in the Angelika or and you the subways
you hear the subways and you just sort
of incorporate it into the movie going
experience because the whole theater
starts to rumble that started to happen
and I thought like I don't remember
mixing that sound and and then we in New
York what's happening right now am I
having a panic attack and then and then
all of a sudden the movie just stopped
completely stopped and for like the
first five minutes you're like oh this
is kind of funny you know ish and then
the house lights go up and and the way
that they seated at the Venice Film
Festival you and Lady gaga we're right
in the middle and then it sort of
ladders down so you're right like in the
minute so the lights Club and everybody
starts turning to us and I'm saying
they're like and you're I'm really lost
like do I do we sing you know and I just
sort of sat there and then they said
yeah they're trying to fix it and then
like 10 minutes go by and then I started
thinking everybody's gonna leave they're
just gonna leave right and then 15
minutes go by and then you start
thinking like oh this is kind of cool
it's kind of like life on life's terms
like look at the community like I
actually got this weird thing and then
20 minutes go by and it's a complete
nightmare and then then the movie
started again and and now far into the
movie worried you were like and thank
God it wasn't in the middle of like a
musical number something if it was like
the end of the first act yeah I'm still
a lot left at the movie and they
actually said you want to start at the
beginning my god no yeah the great a few
step away from the beginning
sooo sit down sit down just really lost
it on these Italian people that would be
great
Lily what's he saying yeah yeah so but
the end that's starting a but that was
excruciating because you know it's like
if you're singing a song and you stop
after the first verse wait twenty
minutes and do the rest of the song yes
so it was it had a totally different
rhythm so I haven't seen it so this
would be the last time I'll see you
tonight which I'm excited about actually
to sit through and watch it
you